buongiorno ragazzi sono sveglio da due
ore però come se mi fosse stato fatto un
clistere di valeriano e per home page e
faccio la cucina mentre parliamo così vi
spiego cosa in mente non nego il fatto
che sta cosa che l'estate non sia stata
cancellata
mi faccia alquanto risicare inizialmente
sembra che saremo mai più tornati al
mare non ci saremmo mai più messi in
costume da bagno o improvvisamente tutto
quanto un bikini ready se non vedo l'ora
di andare in grecia che non capisci chi
sta pigliando pericolo di sé sono quelli
che pensano veramente di andare in
vacanza o quelli che invece ci hanno
detto fino adesso è in vacanza cesare
malnati e invece a quanto pare col
plexiglass improvvisamente sarebbe tutti
quanti in vacanza in costume nuti ora
che mi conosce sa che io accetto tutto
quanto usate questa già nervosa ma la
disney sta dicevo no quindi se il
governo mi dice che dobbiamo sta a casa
e non usciremo mai più che l'estate e
sognate magari italiani sia rosi così
l'estate torna e invece che per la prova
costume
pronto il forno è di qualche giorno fa
esprimeva questo mio feroci disappunto
al mio cugino dicendo ma come che faccio
anche lui l'acido e sereno mi fanno
perché non proprio il digiuno alternato
guardandolo intensamente negli occhi gli
ho chiesto pietra ma che kld c'è un
alternato secondo il sito my personal
trainer punto it che un settore quale
inciampo sempre più spesso con
l'avanzata della mia età non chiedetevi
perché ovviamente tra dolori al buio del
qua consigli su diete personal trainer
copre tutto dicevo secondo questo sito
itg intermittente può aiutare ad
aumentare la massa muscolare e dimagrire
annullare qualsiasi forma di catabolismo
e promuovere la prote'o sintesi e
soprattutto grazie allo streaming lo
insulinico bisogna favorire la napoli
smoke at t shirt con sel digiuno
intermittente grazie a credo di aver
capito di cosa stiamo parlando clienti
si passa dalla dieta del cavernicolo che
prevede un enorme abbuffata con uno due
giorni di digiuno al più ragionato
sistema 16 18 cos'è 16 sono le ore di
digiuno e otto sono quelli nelle quali
vengono consumati due o tre pasti fermo
poi m fermi tutti scusate l'interruzione
ci tenevamo a dire una cosa stiamo
lavorando al video e noi sapevamo
solamente che dovevamo digiunare 16 ore
non ci ha detto niente
sì o fuori per mangiare 16 8 per
mangiare 16 di digiuno proseguiamo un
attimo il video e poi magari ci
rimettiamo più tardi pare che in
condizioni di astinenza alimentare
quello che succede che se ad una canna
insulinica totale e si sviluppi anche
l'ormone anabolico igf 1 sommato me
vabbè alcuni menzionano pure un aumento
del testo stava vette base devi allenare
esempio un passo da consumare appena
alzati fonte proteica e carboidrati a
medio basso indice glicemico pochi
grassi
secondo pasto colazione completa
allenamento terzo vasto da svolgere
subito dopo l'allenamento pranzo
completo finestra di digiuno dalle 13 o
15 circa fino alla mattina seguente ma
una coppia cui elmo ma questo se la
canta e se lo sono io non ho parole cioè
per non ci ha detto nulla
ragazzi non ci ha detto nulla noi non
sapevamo come vedrete nel video non
faremo niente di quello no è assurdo
vedere con che basta io sinceramente era
essere la sua cavia da laboratorio non
ci fa questo è uno scienziato pazzo però
non è la prima volta non ci porta nel
baratro dei suoi spin ma io facciamo un
esperimento una vendetta ci vendichiamo
bellissimo
rimanete collegati i ragazzi e di diremo
in cosa consiste la vendetta ovviamente
se stampo essere adattato allo stile di
vita del soggetto ma personalmente
reputo che questo risulta migliore per
finire il commento di nutrizionista non
commenterà il commento del nutrizionista
che non commenterà poiché apparirmi a si
tratta di un metodo ancora molto giovane
innovativo quindi è tutto un esperimento
una vena diseducativa infatti c'è in
questo caso sull'approccio alla
limitazione è in numerose lacune a
trizio na li certo se tu insegni che un
modo per dimagrire è quello di digiunare
e non mangiare effettivamente non è che
tu stia dando un grandissimo
insegnamento su questo sono d'accordo
con un nutrizionista però finisce con ci
mancherebbe altro tre pasti controllati
a controllate dei quali 2 secondarie un
solo pasto principe del giorno seguiti
da 16 ore di digiuno nella migliore
delle ipotesi non possono altro che
giovarono un soggetto in sovrappeso
sempre che lei resiste alla tortura che
tortura che voglia di provarlo giorno 1
attacco alle 14 non è male a cappello
che questa cosa ed i giorni e
intermittente non è che sia proprio una
cupa sega andrebbe presa eccoci qua
tornava a casa sono le nove
autore comunque di miss fondo un po
primo giorno di roba qua
dell'intermittenza insomma come si
chiama vediamo come va la cosa che mi
chiedo che so io in queste otto ore
posso mangiare come faccia nel senso che
18 ore per mondiale out come sfondo è
quello attore ha fatto il compatto il
modulo sarà dieta in otto ore
capisco allora che ha un senso cioè
muori oppure non capisco il senso di
questa dieta yo come sfondo forse non ho
proprio capito nulla
comincia ufficialmente la dieta del
tempo non so come cazzo si chiama questa
challenge inutile ma trovo la cosa più
inutile che sia mai stata pensata è più
utile avere un buco del comico comunque
a pranzo purtroppo non mi sono ripreso
non ci ho pensato ma ho mangiato verso
le due e mezza sono le 9 nella fascia
oraria che devo rinunciare un pasto
rinuncia la colazione quindi mi sentirei
su 14 22 giusto vediamo ma poi scusate
qualcuno di voi sa chi ha inventato
questa pazza gli abbiamo qualcuno nei
commenti sa dirmi chi è il cretino che
ha inventato questa baggianata per
favore fatemelo sapere perché uno che
dice ora mangio e tra otto ore non posso
più mangiare i neuroni s'è mangiato
eshetu creatore di questa challenge
perché l'hai fatto cioè non è mia
intenzione offendersi anzi si è mia
intenzione offendere ti perché l'hai
fatto perché l'hai fatto
roma svela interrompo le comunicazioni
chiedo scusa all'inventore della dieta e
con guglielmo che me la devo prendere
perdono o ammesso di giorni
intermittente come funziona a dovere
non sto cominciando scusate sono a casa
di gianmarco stiamo rispettando la dieta
del tempo proseguiamo questa inutilità
dai una fetta di ciambellone per la
nostra dieta
la cosa interessante questa dieta è che
non ha restrizioni alimentari ma sono
temporali quindi sì vabbè non ha senso
io volevo continua ribadirlo ormai nei
giorni ma non è una dieta appena mangi
il primo cibo dopo otto ore in this
attono però quello che faccio io è ok ma
gioco a quest'ora tra otto ore quindi
devo fare il passo finale centri dentro
grazie cena io sto na favola stadio
colazione tramite una cucina raggirata
completa diciamo che tra un anno ma
qualcosa che dice meglio smettere di
mangiare chi avesse convento della
rivista mi chiamate nel tempo e senza ma
mi sa che io l'altro ieri ho detto che
ieri avrei fatto tutto quanto in maniera
più dietetica no affatto
posso dire una cosa mi fa cagare stato
l'on silicon di giorni intermittente
gioco consiglio terzo giorno già nuovo
consiglio ora senso io adesso devo
aspettare il 14 per arrivare con gli
occhi di fuori di curarmi qualsiasi cosa
che ci fa uno spuntino piccolo adesso a
qualcuno di voi l'ha mai fatto il
digiuno intermittente li ha funzionato
mezzogiorno mancano due ore lo faccio 14
mi piace l'idea di dover stare a dieta
già di per sé e poi dover pure aspetta
stitici ore prima di mangiare visco
mangiare un pezzo di polistirolo i due
minuti un piatto di pasta ogni 24 ore
sono arrivate le 14 era viene ha portato
burrata e crudo quindi anche oggi non si
farà la dieta normale
ovviamente le già mangiato come fattori
sono adesso più e mezza allora fa ho
mangiato presto ma non puoi non è 14 59
quando le pari da poi otto ore dopo non
mangio tanto buongiorno uno vuol dire i
ragazzi non lo sapranno questa che si è
scordato di montevideo questo p4 ha
sgarrato che vergogna un fallimento
poi ci siamo proprio abbandono nave e
anche oggi non ha minimamente collina mi
seguirete giusti
sono le nove e un quarto ha mangiato la
prima volta oggi così alle 21 nella
timeline ma era calata st dieta io mi
scordo che esiste questa dieta per
quanto dichiarato da parte del tar
minerale da false stata una vasta e stai
vedeva e vede la vera 30 tel provaci
pomodori queste le marche a frutta alla
faccia della dieta da marco il medico si
è appena detto io non ho mai fallito tu
cosa hai bevuto giorno quei beni anche
lì disanima e benetton bevande
zuccherine soda beh questo non mi era
stato riferito che per fortuna io sono
bravo e non ho fallito con questa dieta
è facile ieri è venuto enrico l'abbiamo
raggirata proprio ora io ho fame però
arriverò alle due senza grosse
difficoltà trasformerà le risponderò
prima di cena mi funziona così deve
avere comunque un approccio dietetico
ma l'anno e non è non è vero giro la
mattina senza mangiare ci si può stare
visto
quello che dicevano nel sito è dicono
sfondasse quindi oggi però a fare una
cosa aspetta da 14 ma quando iniziano a
mangiare e cercherò comunque di rimanere
a dieta e non sono le 14 facendo si vede
che il tuo orario l'anno scorso un altro
prima no enrico staccati subito non puoi
attacca il telefono
devo dire una cosa era l'una e mezza e
alla fine non è neanche mangiate almeno
me lo ricordo lui è il biscotto assalto
alla diligenza alle 14 ragazzi sono e
non è così che si fa arrestati giudici
la dieta del tempo c'è qualcosa che non
torna in questo di giugno
dopo aver visto questa buffonata mettere
si commenta da solo e arrivato il
momento di chiamare gli altri ma
vogliamo citare il pubblico a scrivere
un luogo o buffone
per questo episodio solo medica scrivete
nei commenti gelmo buffon non saprà
niente guglielmo buffone vi prego
bombardati i commenti con guglielmo
buffone vogliamo chiamare e svelare il
nostro piano cioè che tocca anche a noi
certo salve ragazzi dobbiamo dare una
notizia
abbiamo pensato di fare un torneo per il
prossimo blog perché visto che boyle
scegliete sempre perché si è rigirata
vendola contrario si tratta di una
settimana senza farsi la doccia